how often do you audition for the lead
role or the romantic interest never
never i've never i've submitted for a
few um and usually they're in
projects that are all african-american
you know like like a web series or that
kind of thing but i've not been
considered like the love interest like
ever
and that's one thing it's funny because
i did a web series in new york and
the director i mean it was a great
script it but the woman that i was
portraying was like single and like
never able to find a date and that kind
of thing and i and i kind of mentioned
well hey
why do we perpetuate this kind of idea
that african-american women are not
marriageable or not able to find love
it's just kind of bugs me so i think
it's kind of like a
a double-edged sword like
you you know that in our in the
community african-american community
that creates films it's like that cookie
cutter but then if you want to go
outside of that it's it's it's not
possible because they don't see us as
the love interest so to speak
um i think like actresses like um
mindy colleen like she's been doing
great on her own doing that which is i
think what i would have to do in order
to break through that all the time like
i said once again if i if i can make
that opportunity happen i make it happen
um a lot of times i'm told like well
we're looking for another type of
you know character and i'll still
audition for it anyway once again
because it's like i enjoy the passion of
just actually getting the opportunity
to act you know but yeah lead role
principal the superhero i go for those
auditions all the time because i am that
person you know i'm trey carson i am a
leader you know i
i innovate you know i i learn i teach
you know so i go for anything that's
going to fill me as a person i've
auditioned for the lead once so far in
my acting career in los angeles and it
was for a disney channel show
and i was playing the older sister
so that was fun that's an excellent
question you should ask
you should ask kelsey grammer that see
he's an expendables three and they're
touting him as an action hero now i
haven't seen expendables three that's an
excellent question
i've i've considered myself a a
character actor
i would like to say
hero parts i've i've on stage i've been
angry a lot a lot of the roles i've been
i play anger very well a lot of the
roles have been angry roles and
so on and so on
as a hero that's a good question i was
my largest stage role
line wise and and and lead was i drove i
drive miss daisy i played that at santa
monica college uh in
1994. had the lead role hulk coleman the
role that morgan freeman originated on
broadway in the role that he did in the
film
uh that's the longest lead wrote you
could say he's a hero of sorts uh
he
he was very humble
but he's also he stood stood his ground
again for the uh
the character that jessica tandy played
in the film
i would like dodgers from working with
royals no i you know i don't ask i don't
get auditions for the hero roles very
very much and like a lot of the
breakdowns that i'll see you know the
hero role is guy's caucasian and you
know
the villain or like the third or fourth
guy in charge is like the
african-american dude but he gets killed
off pretty early you know he gets killed
like third scene eaten by the monster or
stabbed by whatever or blown up or
whatever and so
you know
i've never had the opportunity to
audition for the role where like
my character perseveres to the whole
film and at the end of the thing the
credits roll and yeah it was one film i
did
a year and a half ago where
i played a cop and actually he was
actually the good guy and he didn't he
didn't actually get killed but that's
like so few and far between
it's not even really worth mentioning
i go for principal roles first always do
always have
um
yeah i want to get in the action i want
to be in there but it does depend on the
type of principal role
if they're if i had a choice between a
principal role and a character a
supporting character role that's really
juicy i'm going to go for the character
now when i started i would have would
not have
but the other one is a little more
challenging a little more depth
you know finding that humanity in some
of those crazy people that you play
that's really fun that's really the fun
part of of this whole
aspect this whole acting business i
think is is really doing the the
backstory and the analysis and all of
that
so that is what i would go for now um
but i get cast a lot in leads
i do i i even when i'm going out for
supporting they've changed me to the
lead a few times i do you know i
you know i submit to the heroes and
you know the the principal roles uh i
don't i don't discriminate
even though i embrace these these
these other roles that we talked about
i i'm an actor and
you know i embrace all roles so yes i do
so even if you know look they want me to
be somebody that i'm really not i'm the
total opposite but if they need me to go
there it's still acting it's still a job
right well there's there's been
occasions where you know i i go in as as
the bad guy
and they see me in a different light as
a hero
but yet because either the hero is not
dark enough or the other character is
not dark enough
you know they they always get me
but it's just it's just good to see that
that they see me in that light as well
you